en 2019 le ministre québécois de
l'agriculture André la montagne
déclarait que le rapport prenovo était
son étoile du Nord ce rapport paru il y
a 15 ans continue d'inspirer certaines
réformes mais plusieurs de ces
recommandations ont été ignorées alors
quel est l'héritage de ce fameux rapport
de Jean prenovo sur l'avenir de
l'agriculture
l'agriculture doit contribuer notamment
à l'occupation dynamique du territoire à
la revitalisation des collectivités
rurales à la production de bien en
alimentaire et environnementaux et à la
configuration des paysages elle est
aussi un mode de vie et contribue à
notre identité culturelle
[Musique]
le son est ajusté
le rapport pour nous le rapport pour
nous tous les rapports d'une commission
une commission créée par le gouvernement
qui s'était appelé la Commission sur
l'avenir de l'agriculture et dont le but
était de faire l'état de la situation et
de finalement faire des recommandations
gouvernement pour ajuster bien sûr les
actions gouvernementales les programmes
notamment à la réalité de ces années-là
on est en 2006 quand le rapport
renouveau a été publié le public ne
connaissait pas Jean prenevaux qui
était-il quand je l'ai connu
vous parlait ou l'écouter dans le sens
que c'était un homme qui avait une
sagesse en lui les agriculteurs
pourraient toutefois choisir tous la
même association la lecture qu'on
faisait à l'époque et j'étais au centre
de cette situation là est en soumise
c'était celle d'une agriculture qui est
en mutation importante d'une part il y
avait une sorte de clivage qui se
faisait entre les grandes fermes de plus
en plus
important donc des fermes appelées
industrielles et de petites fermes
souvent des initiatives difficiles à
placer parce que les programmes
gouvernementaux lui répondaient pas
entre les deux la ferme complet assez
familiale moyenne typique est en train
de disparaître complètement donc on
comptait dans ça
[Musique]
en raison entre autres de la perte des
fermetures les villages ont périphérie
des grands centres se vidait et les
fermes étaient très endettés plus que
les entreprises agricoles canadiennes
comparables
alors le résultat on avait des secteurs
ou des productions qui étaient elles
très avantagée et de l'autre côté non
plus rien je savais qu'un jour ou
l'autre j'étais pour m'acheter une ferme
deux ans de travaux près de 800 mémoires
et autant de personnes venues s'exprimer
confortent le président prenovo dans sa
lecture on peut pas dissocier
agriculture
occupation du territoire et
développement économique régional ça
marche ensemble
[Musique]
une recommandation du rapport proposait
l'arrivée de nouvelles associations
professionnelles d'agriculteurs ce qui
aurait brisé le monopole de l'Union des
producteurs agricoles l'UPA la question
du pluralisme syndical avait fait grand
bruit en 2008
[Musique]
en fait ce que monsieur prenovo le
Président
disait c'est permettre l'émergence de
nouvelles associations professionnelles
représentatives des agriculteurs et non
pas la représentation unique est-ce que
le combat
disons les urgences contre cette
recommandation là éclipsé tout le reste
cette recommandation là
elle était dans l'esprit de Jean renovo
essentiel d'abord parce qu'il l'avait
entendu beaucoup et qu'il voyait
également que une bonne partie du
problème dont il parlait d'une
agriculture qui manquait d'oxygène était
dans le fait qu'on avait une fois une
représentation qui était qui était
unique dans son modèle et également un
contrôle
en plusieurs absolus des structures de
mise en marché de l'agriculture s'il y
avait une recommandation une seule que
vous voudriez quand qu'on retienne ce
serait laquelle
curieusement c'est pas celle sur le
plaisir syndicales qui m'apparaîtrait le
plus importantes
ce serait simple lequel j'ai travaillé
celle sur le soutien l'agriculture
revoir complètement
la nos modes de soutien c'est comme ça
dans le fond que une des recommandations
et c'est d'ouvrir le soutien
à toutes les entreprises agricoles
mais comme la majorité du rapport
laissant bien souvent les petites fermes
et les jeunes des avantagés
c'est beaucoup plus facile d'aller
chercher 100000 dollars additionnels sur
une ferme en mode érigie que d'aller
chercher même 10000 dollars pour mettre
en place une première culture de quelque
chose qui se fait moins
peur de la Place aux jeunes la
commission modèle de ferme pour entre
autres dynamiser le territoire en 2008
tout comme encore aujourd'hui 40% du
territoire agricole n’était pas en
exploitation le filet de sécurité qui
protège traditionnel traditionnellement
notre agriculture devient de moins en
moins performant et doit être mis à jour
il ne s'agit surtout pas d'abandonner
nos filets de protection mais de les
adapter il faut aérer le système pour
faire place aux nouvelles réalités
la sera qui compense la différence entre
le coup de production et le prix du
marché ne touche que quelques
productions et les agences de mise en
marché couvrent une quinzaine de
productions agricoles
beaucoup d'autres productions qui
pourraient être notamment les
légumineuses qui sont un peu la source
protéinique de l'avenir ben encore ici
aujourd'hui on la voit pas naître c'est
un peu dans l'esprit de ce qu'il disait
on étouffe tout ça donc ça laisse pas
beaucoup de place parce que quel est
l'intérêt économique à produire quelque
chose si on n'a pas nié soutien
gouvernemental d'une structure de mise
en marché qui permet d'aller chercher le
prix voilà c'est ça on en vient toujours
au soutien universel
c'est aussi au nom de l'agriculture
plurielle que la Commission recommande
de rendre l'admissible au programme
d'aide financière tous les types de
production
différentes initiatives gouvernementales
dans l'esprit des recommandations du
rapport ont été mises de l'avant comme
le développement des cultures en serre
l'aide financière à la transition vers
une culture biologique et des pratiques
agro-environnementales ou encore les
circuits courts c'est à dire comme
rédaction les productions Acer
commencent à devenir dans l'esprit des
gens bon une solution à notre
alimentation de proximité bon ça
commence à là donc j'ai eu des
programmes pour ça on a des mesures mais
on n'a pas de politique une politique
c'est beaucoup plus large que ça ça part
justement d'une lecture et ça va vers
voilà où on s'en va c'est un programme
pour l'avenir c'est un programme pour
les 5 10 15 prochaines années et ce
programme là devrait être inspirant
un gouvernement qui dirait voilà où
est-ce qu'on s'en va
moi je serai satisfait de voir ça un
jour
[Musique]
sans renier les gains importants nous
croyons qu'il faut faire preuve d'autant
d'audace qu'à l'époque qui nous a
précédé afin de redéfinir la place de
l'agriculture dans la société
[Musique]